okay why don't we start good morning my
name is someone huh from a Microsoft
quantum team I'm one of the researchers
in the team and I'm going to tell you
well I'm going to give you a brief
overview of on computing years what is
it and why we do it and how we do it
so the first well we would like to
understand what quantum computing is
computing by in general means that it is
to manage and process and communicate
information for various purposes I don't
want to define what the information is I
just rely on your intuition so we give
you an what the one of the first general
purpose computer computer looked like it
is a Aniak in the installed in the
pennsylvania making the 40's and it was
designed for the purpose of calculating
the trajectory of a ballistic missile
and then you put the first program in
ran was actually not about that
ballistic missile but about some nuclear
physics calculation initiated by just
don't run for more money on others for
the manhattan project
so it was Kathleen some physical process
actually now with the invent with the
invention of transistor the machine does
so smaller and so much faster and the
physical reason that the Technol the
physics that enable this techno
technological innovation was based on
the quantum physics but quantum
computing is not about that quantum
physics here it's more of a fundamental
level so what is that so to give you an
idea let me begin with the probabilistic
computing what is a problem based
computing let me give an example say I
give you a function that's defined on a
hundred variables and I ask you to find
the integral of that how would you do
that it's 100 dimensional so if you make
a fine mesh along say 100 mesh points
along his ration and the number of
points you have the sample would be 102
100 astronomical number you shouldn't do
that
but more straightforward way is that you
randomly sample points in the theta
average that will give you a very
reliable estimate of the integral and
for all practical purposes that's the
best but you know another random
algorithm is that if I give you a black
box of function polynomial function I
guarantee that you this it function is a
polynomial in say hundred variables then
how would you say this is nonzero well
if I don't tell you anything about the
function in the only deterministic
algorithm that we know of is essentially
going through all possible inputs there
will be like well if the x1 in our
binary are variables then there will be
two to the hundred so you shouldn't do
that but the problem is method is that
you simply randomly sample input points
and test a perceiver and surprisingly
there's no deterministic algorithm is
known for this problem another probably
a practical your active useful algorithm
is that if I give you a factorization of
a1 matrix C into a times B and how would
you check that the as a factorization is
correct well you could do the matrix
multiplication and that will impact this
close to the end cube complexity but
randomized algorithm can do it faster
because you can randomly sample on the
input vector and then check the output
of the two equations and you could do it
sufficient many times then you have a
high confidence that the equation is
correct and that's good for our purposes
so theoretically we can imagine the this
problem is computing in this way we
start with just a flat distribution over
some number of variables and then my
algorithm transforms that distribution
under the classical rules and we end up
with a some concentrated distribution
that is hopefully constant concentration
around the desired solution this is the
this is what's going on
now observe that the probability space
the space of all probability
distributions at the individual nav
it has exponentially many entries and in
any propolis computing we don't keep
track of this probability density
function but we just work over examples
similar principle carries over to the
quantum computing the difference is that
you take a square root so if I had a bit
then there will be a two numbers well
it's actually essentially one number
because I am constrained to the
condition that the probably
probabilities had to sum to one and I
can denote that probability as a two
component vector with the positive reals
in the quantum computing we take a
square root so each of the entries the
state of my well square root space of
square roots probably the probabilities
will reside on the complex numbers and
each entry takes values in the complex
number whose modulus is between 0 and 1
and with a rule that the amplitude
squared is equal to 1 now here the
amplitude is a technical word to mean
the square root of probability so that's
cubed and it is apparent that if I have
a n qubits then there will be
exponentially many complex numbers to
describe that distribution however in
analogy with the probability computing
we do not keep track of each amplitude
we shouldn't because there are too many
and some fundamental feature of the
quantum physics relates the two models
if I start with a some quantum amplitude
vector if I look at it look is a rather
not to appropriate but this most close
term in the libyans word if I look at it
then I would get the
I'll come 0 with the probability given
by the amplitude squared and probability
1 with amplitude given by this I would
probably be given by them play the
square again and in a sense this
fundamental property of quantum physics
limits our ability to use the quantum
physics because we're back to the
probability instead of the world of
amplitudes and to exploit that
quantumness here are the elementary
gates unlike the classical circuit where
everything can be generated by NAND
gates there are several in a quantum
case but not too many there are only
well I listed actually over complete set
I only need this much this and that and
that one you can omit that one for
example because this one is is a
application of twice of that and the one
notable feature of those matrices is
that they are all unitary why unitary
why do we need a linear algebra here so
the the fundamental feature that quantum
phase is quantum measurements maps of
amplitudes to probabilities we shouldn't
measure them
we shouldn't collapse them you shouldn't
intervene the intermediate step of
quantum computation well if you do so
then you're about to the classical
probability computing you're not
exploiting the qantas here so we
shouldn't look at it and the only way to
not look at it but somehow operate is to
go through the unitary operation and and
therefore we have a unitary set
and I want to emphasize that unlike some
popular social media exploits it quantum
is knots are real in the following
technical sense in the probables
computing I'm repeating myself it was
all handled by the exponentially many
positive real numbers that's up to one
taking the square root your end up with
exponentially many complex numbers whose
modular squared sum is one and quantum
circuit is nothing but a unitary matrix
multiplication on that gigantic vector
therefore a logician will say Oh
anything that can be done with the
quantum computer can be done on the
classical computer there is no empirical
difference anything that can be decided
in the classical computer can be done in
quantum and vice-versa
however as a computer scientist not
every finer things are equal some things
are much harder because you have to go
through many more steps to accomplish a
job and that's where the component
computing is so why do we care about the
quantum because it can sometimes address
classically intractable problems and I'm
giving a 2 or 3 most famous examples
here so there are quantum algorithm
primitives that we use over and over
again we are waiting for a new primitive
but so far these are pretty much
complete least so one probably the
famous one is the first one the starch
over the database of n entries can be
done in the square root time instead of
looking at n entries there's a quadratic
speed-up and a similar principle can be
applied to the sampling problem where
you where your accuracy converge is much
faster instead of
the in order to achieve the absolute
accuracy in your statistical measurement
then you have to go through one over
epsilon squared number of samples to
achieve that goal but you know
particular quantum setting that accuracy
convergence can be made quite radically
faster and the Fourier transform which
typically oh yeah which in the classical
world takes about n log n time where you
have a n component vector this becomes
exponentially faster you lose you you
you you you forget about that ant vector
but left with a log in that and certain
aspects of linear equation can be
obtained and exponentially faster in the
number in the dimension if you have a
matrix of condition number Kappa then
classically you need n square root of
Kappa number of operations to calculate
something about the solution but
quantumly the the dependence and the
condition number remains but the
dimension factor the dimension
dependence gets exponentially better but
note that B all these primitives are
applicable only for the data that are
generated on the fly it cannot be used
for real data for a simple reason it
takes linear time to even to load the
data so there's a bottleneck however
there is a exponentially exponential
speed-up in the case of for the
user-defined data when it comes to the
simulation of quantum physics so
remember that ENIAC was first used to
simulate classical physics now quantum
computing is natural to solve problems
that involves simulation of quantum
physics and the in this exponential
speed-up is very typical natural so what
can we do with that the one appealing
example is the following you may be
surprised that the ammonia molecule
consumes well the production of ammonia
it consumes like a 5
percent of all global natural gas
consumption or like two or three percent
or one or two percent of all global
energy consumption because it could eat
the this chemical process in the at the
industrial level it requires like
hundreds of degree of temperature and
the hungriest times times the
atmospheric pressure so to to make that
environment you need a lot of heat and
surprisingly the there are some bacteria
in at the roots over some vegetable that
does this job at the room temperature at
the natural atmospheric pressure and
after several decades of research
actually we don't know why it's likely
more in depth there there the bacteria
has a special enzyme and the in the
middle of that enzyme there there lies a
this particular molecule I'll iron
Malita Malita and cofactor it's called
it's not too complicated molecule it
involves like a hundreds of atoms it's
not terribly complicated and this
molecule is believed to be the key for
this process that converts nitrogen a
molecule in combined with the hydrogen
to produce ammonia and to understand how
this works we need to compute the
energies of various chemical
configurations and that is
computationally limited even the the
fastest supercomputer is not sufficient
to address this problem and you may
expect that some experiment will tell us
how this molecule works but it is still
crude maybe this process involves like a
several tens of steps each of which is
hard to compute and we don't know how it
happens if we understand how it happens
then there's a check good chance that we
can utilize them and to make the ammonia
production much more efficient and some
estimates so I'm very shy until a
reasonable estimate tells us that even
very small scale quantum computer can
help us here like a one that has only
two hundred cubits or so may be able to
help under help us understand how this
molecular works in another famous
example for the application of quantum
computing is the the factoring problem
almost all cryptography practical
protocols may relies on the hardness of
factoring if you could if I give you a
composite number and don't tell you
about the prime factors then it is hard
for you to figure out what those private
vectors are and based on that we build
out the public encryption schemes and if
you have a like I say hundred the course
in the classical computer then merely
factory and thousand bit numbers takes
about order of a year and if you
increase that number to a two thousand
then that will take a order of the age
of universe to compute extrapolating the
current technology but if you have a
quantum computer that you that has
thousands of qubits then that problem
can be solved in the order of days well
this all this is due to the exponential
scaling you see initial gap here the for
smaller sizes quantum computer will not
be a cup help because of the huge
constant factor I will get to that huge
constant factor later so if we then then
this poses a great problem or great
concern to the world of cryptography
if the pub if the current technology is
broke it will be broken by on the
computer what should we do
the quantum physics helps again here
there is a private key distribution
protocol based on the quantum physics in
such a way that any investor pain will
be detected and is guaranteed by the
laws of physics any inherent Lee uses
the quantum correlations so called
entanglement and robust implementation
is still being developed
and to to protect our information in the
post quantum era in the future there is
a quantum resistant classical crypto
methods and there are candidates and it
will replace the current probably keep
crypto systems based on the factory and
with a requirement that it should be
interoperable with the existing facility
the mentioned the quality private key
distribution is not it's not considered
in this proposal and such a purely
classical algorithm is now being
standardized by Liszt
it's I heard that it is round to where
like a tens of protocols are the
competing with each other to find the
best one so so that was major
applications or easy to access
application so upon the computing now
how do we make one what are the
challenges and what where we are now
there are many obstructions in the in
architecture of a computer in any
computer there should be an hardware
that actually operates something and
there should be a some programming
support to control that hardware and on
top of that we have to think about what
algorithms can we learn and at Microsoft
we have investments in all stages and
how to make one in this talk will be
focused on the hardware side and you
will hear more about the quantum
programming side in today later so there
are many qubits proposed developed by
that various industrial companies some
are based on the faults on its
polarization some are based on the
superconducting devices and you take a
very particular physical states in this
device and some are thinking about the
quantum dots your your separate where
you isolate very tiny atoms or
artificial atoms
in your leg some are thinking about the
atoms that are trapped in in an optical
lattice we are thinking about a
topological qubit what is a topological
qubit that may sound scary but not so
much so let me tell you a bit more about
so to motivate let me give you the
classical error correction the overhead
let's talk about the classical era
crashing overhead here is a picture of
deep space probe that we have to
communicate over and if the
communication is very noisy you can't
really hear the clear sound over that
probe that are in the deep space lightly
well not light years but it takes it
takes for light to travel
it takes about I don't know a few hours
to try it for the light to travel to
that probe so imagine that each video
sent is corrupted by the other bit it's
it's your bilious fleet but up with some
small probability then then you can
correct those you can fight with those
noises by make redundant message so you
send 0 0 0 in place of 0 and triple ones
in place of 1 we say that these beats
are physical bits are actually sent and
these beats are logical piece that we
meant to send now the receiver which can
be at the probe or us decodes
potentially corrupted data if I receive
triple zero or two two zeros and one
that I and I would infer that message
was just zero in the other case I infer
the message to be one and that's
reliable because the logical error
probability that is I inferred it was
zero but the sender actually meant one
or vice versa that logical error
probability gets smaller for any for a
given physical error rate by this
repeating our procedure and if you do it
more clever well you could do that
analysis
and given the fiscal error rate the
number of actual physical beats that you
have to send as a function of this
physical error rate given the target
logical error rate scales like this so
as long as your error probability is
less than half then you can achieve you
can send some information but the number
of actual physical piece that you have
to send increases quite rapidly if
you're if your physical noise is the
exactly the same thing happens in the
quantum world too so even with even
though we are dealing with the quantum
information the square root of
probabilities we can fight with errors
by encoding our according information
into the correlation of quantum
particles and there exists a quantum
error correcting code in as much as we
have a repetition classical error
correcting code and the similar analysis
tells us this figure if you want to
achieve logical error rate to be 10 to
minus 10 here the error rate is the the
probability that the qubit is corrupted
given a clock cycle or a message if you
wish if we wish to achieve this very
small logical error probability then if
you're a physical error rate you say
0.1% then you would have to deal with
thousands of qubit you have to send oh
you need a thousand cubits only to send
one qubit but that number dramatically
decreases if the physical error rate is
decreasing now not a difference
the clock in the classical world the
threshold below which we can send any
information was half zero point one in
the quantum case it is order of
magnitude smaller and that's the
challenge we are facing that's why we do
not have a general-purpose quantum
computer
so it is critical for scalability to
achieve low physical error rate
otherwise the overhead from their from
the air crashing will be too large and
here comes well and that that
differentiates our approach from more
conventional approach the one of their
prevalence technology to build a cubit
is based on the superconducting circuits
and they have error rate around here so
you will need approximately of thousands
of qubit to make a general-purpose cone
computer but topological qubit if we
have one it is expected to have much
lower error rate hence much smaller
overhead from the economy crashing
that's why we are focusing on good care
of it and that is very analogous to the
this peak this picture if you have a
chalk board you and you write something
here the writer was counting something
obviously the small small particle in
your chalk is attached to your
blackboard by a some very weight
chemical bond or friction but it can be
easily washed away it doesn't really
have a correlation between the amount of
tooth and it doesn't fight with noise
anymore but if you count using knots as
the old ink indeed then it can last for
thousands of years because as long as a
string is unbroken the fact that there
is not isn't invariant so topological
qubit conceptually in a very abstract
level does the same job so here's an
actual example where the where that
autonomous correlation helps this is a
figure from
1980 paper where they measured so-called
Hulk conductance across the sample under
a hype low temperature and the high
magnetic field and they just measure the
resists resistance of that sample across
the certain big configuration what they
found was that there is a plateau in the
resistance there are pretty wide and
resilient to external parameters they
tested various geometries and various
other settings
they even alter the current year
ascending and they didn't see any change
and this accuracy is so remarkable that
it is for what know for a long time used
as used as the calibration standard
whatever example you make how dirty you
are it doesn't really matter the the
autocorrelation amount of electrons
gives you robustness and we want to
qubit that exhibits a similar phenomena
so there is a proposal theoretical
proposal that the signals that oh there
if you fabricate such a device by
putting a some very small wire on top of
very special with material in a low
temperature and apply certain magnets
then there will be a some hidden states
that we can use to build a qubit and one
signature for that purpose has been
experimentally observed so we are
optimistic that we will be able to find
a material and setting such that the the
many-body electrons help us to build a
qubit and that's what we are focusing on
that's how we are going to build a
quantum computer so that's a recap what
I have said this morning so don't be
scared about the quantum computing it's
just a square root of probability a
probabilistic computing and to make use
of that quantumness we should remain in
the space of amplitude
instead of probabilities and that's why
we should use the unitary operations
instead of other classical analogues and
naturally this quantum the setting can
simulate quantum systems efficiently
whose job is intractably on a classical
computer and therefore what a computer
will likely have applications in the
common chemistry and material science
and on top of that there is some
computational problems including the
factoring is becomes much easier on the
quantum computer and the quantumness is
more subtle than excuse me more subtle
than the classical counterparts so to
overcome the overhead from the error
correction the physical qubits fidelity
is very important and we are focusing on
a very good qubit instead of many and we
are our qalam
covers whole every aspect of that from
hardware to intermediate program
language to higher level algorithms and
others and you may wish to check out our
websites that illustrates further
conceptual explanations and our
programming our tool sets and you will
hear more about it later this today and
I'm ready to take your questions thank
you
how long do you think it'll take before
you have a functioning topological qubit
is it one year ten years well I you're
not allowed to say yeah I personally
don't know it's still under
investigation
so iBM has already functioning quantum
systems in their cloud but that's not
based on topological right that's the
residents magnetic residents I think or
I'm not sure so do you have any as
already thought that that's what they're
doing is any good or is it if there's
something interesting device in the
interesting in that you can actually
implement some experiments and apply
gates there but it's only five cubits or
well I I forgot the exact number maybe I
shouldn't say five it anyway small
number and anything that can be done
Condor machine it can't be done I see
malaria to very easily so scientifically
interesting and we'll see where we go
get your example of the ammonia locking
so how is it that a quantum model helps
us here is the steady state or because
it doesn't give us anything with with
respect to time C time involving Oh
actually a good question
in fact in quantum computer is much
better to simulate dynamic scenes that
are estimating static properties however
but the time scale where the chemical
reactions happen is far smaller than
other thermal time scale so that's why
we are asking about the stepping numbers
there and the quantum computer can help
there too because you can estimate the
energy of intermediate steps so you know
the catalyst is like a financing you
will make a profit in the end but to do
to make to that to make a dot profit you
have to invest it too much and that's
why some processes are as too slow in
nature and the catalyst is like
intermediate financing facility where
you learn small money and then make a
small profit and you to keep doing to to
reach the eventual goal and how we land
money and where to run money depends on
the molecular structure and the typical
method would be well okay here here is
my catalyst to understand that well let
me attach an atom here how much energy
do I get and you need to calculate that
oh if I do if I know that energy then I
can calculate the rate the chemical
reaction happens along that direction
and you do with many times here the
bottleneck used to estimate that energy
and the current computer will go
facilitate that process you you encode
your molecule into account quantum
computer and oh and let it find the
ground state and you make a measurement
the classical method exists but there
are very crude so you're basically
finding the global minimum in a high
dimensional function it is it is like
that yes
yes yes but it's much more it's much
better than the combinatorial case
because it is supposed to be a nature
thing so you can simulate what nature
does in the quantum computer and find
the ground state energy one more
question so I read a lot about quantum
inspired algorithms yes as as people
talk about as quantum computing will
overtake classical computing then they
keep especially in computations as they
thought there are no fast classical
solutions quantum inspired algorithms
keep popping up is that something that
that you see in your work and the
research looking for new algorithms that
you run across quantum inspired ones I
think you will hear more about that like
it in ten minutes
so I defer that quick answer to that
talk okay thank you very much
[Applause]